bonjour est ce que vous m'entendez
jours
[Musique]
alors nous avons commencé ce
webinaire alors je suis sandrine chan je
m'occupe de la communication de la
chambre de métiers d'artisanat de
l'essonne je vous souhaite la bienvenue
et merci de participer à cette quatrième
édition de ma journée découverte des
métiers
organisé par la chambre de métiers et
d'artisanat de l'essonne en partenariat
avec la faculté des métiers et gris le
cfa du bâtiment devrait dîner sur orge
et les apprentis d'auteuil à marcoussis
les cinq web conférence que nous
proposons aujourd'hui dans le cadre de
la jours de la semaine nationale de la
partie serre
sont consacrés à l'orientation des
jeunes vers des métiers de l'automobile
du goût de la fleuristerie de la beauté
et du bâtiment avant de commencer je
voudrais simplement vous livrer quelques
informations sur le secteur de
l'apprentissage sur le secteur de
l'artisanat et sur l'apprentissage qui
attire de plus en plus de jeunes et des
adultes en reconversion
alors l'artisanat représente
1,3 million d'entreprises en france on
l'a
elle l'a plus la première entreprise de
france en ile de france elle compte 1000
entreprises artisanales et en essonne on
compte 31 mille entreprises artisanales
plus d'un tiers des apprentis
sont formés par des dirigeants
d'entreprises artisanales ce qui est
important à thiers
l'apprentissage fait ainsi partie de
l'adn de l'artisanat
il faut savoir que la formation en
apprentissage offre de très belles
perspectives d'avenir pour les jeunes
soit
en étant salarié à l'issue de leur
formation à 80% des ventes des apprentis
trouvent un emploi à l'issue de leur
formation dans les six mois qui suivent
leur apprentissage soit pour être
entrepreneur 41% des chefs d'entreprises
artisanales actuels ont eu et ont été
apprenti dans leur jeunesse voilà de
quoi alimenter vos discussions et
j'espère que ce webinaire va susciter
des vocations
place maintenant à la présentation
de la filière des métiers de
l'automobile et donc nous accueillons
autour de la table
ophélie roux qui est coordinatrice de la
vie sociale et professionnelle pour la
section automobile à la faculté de mitri
abigaël qui est apprenti c'est ap hm ko
three
bonjour abigaël merci d'être venus a big
n
têtu et en quelle année de ces ape moi
j'ai fait ainsi la paix en maman parce
qu'avant
j'ai passé deux diplomates allez donc
j'ai passé un bac pro accompagnement
soins et services à la personne pour
ensuite faire un diplôme
d'aide-soignante j'ai travaillé pendant
cinq ans et demi en tant qu'aide
soignante et j'ai décidé de changer et
du coup je me suis inscrite l'année
dernière vous aviez rock et je crois que
la seule fille de la classe exact qui
compte combien d'élèves dans ta classe
11 11
et à ma droite il y a mano à
mano aqla à pompignan pts maintenant
quel a été ton parcours
alors j'ai commencé par un bac es
et technologique en fait ensuite
à ce que tu vois déjà le
temps des prix
et ensuite
[Musique]
et s maintenance en bts maintenance des
véhicules donc ça veut dire que c'est la
réparation alors en pet est plus subtil
en fait c'est du diagnostic surtout
d'accord parce que je connais mes
chroniques il y aura de plus en plus
d'accord
alors nous allons commencer cette
présentation n'hésitez pas à poser vos
questions sur le tchat nous allons
relever vos questions et nous y
répondrons en fin de de webinaires dans
une demi-heure environ une demi heure 40
minutes je laisse la parole à aurélie
qu'il va vous faire une présentation de
ce qu'est l'apprentissage et les
conditions d'intégration dans 3 cf tout
à fait merci beaucoup
alors je vais vous laisser découvrir un
petit peu le powerpoint
donc voilà l'apprentissage
quelques mots comme vous le voyez à sur
sur l'écran c'est plus à la faculté des
métiers en tout cas c
et puis là + 5 nous travaillons avec des
entreprises par car bien évidemment
puisque l'apprentissage se fait en
alternance chez nous entre le cfa et les
entreprises et c'est pour une grosse
partie nos jeunes 90% un job à la clé
cette formation prépare à 1
indication qui est donc l'apprentissage
en quelques mots en quoi ça consiste
ça s'adresse à un public de jeunes entre
15 et 29 ans révolus c'est une formation
qui est dispensé comme je vous le disais
tout à l'heure entre le cfa et
l'entreprise en alternance donc ça peut
être une alternance d'une semaine une
semaine quinze jours qu'un jour ça va
dépendre des secteurs d'activité
différents métiers il va permettre aux
jeunes d'acquérir simultanément aussi
bien les connaissances théoriques que
des compétences professionnelles au
qu'une certaine expérience la durée elle
va être variable en fonction des
diplômes préparés on peut aller sur une
durée de un an comme avigail tout à
l'heure vous l'expliqué sur des
formations complémentaires jusqu'à des
durées de trois ans pour des bacs on
peut aller jusqu'à 50 si ensuite après
le bac on prépare un bts par exemple on
a des jeunes qui restent longtemps chez
nous vous verrez tout à l'heure qu'on
peut bifurquer en soi différents métiers
quand on a des jeunes qui peuvent rester
huit ans au sein de la filière
automobile
au niveau de la formation en
apprentissage elle est rémunérée c'est
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure
donc elle est calculée sur la base du
smic
c'est cette rémy nation elle va dépendre
de plusieurs critères elle va dépendre
de l'âge de l'apprenti elle va dépendre
de son année de formation également donc
un apprenti qui va rentrer en première
année va avoir un certain pourcentage du
smic s'il a entre 16 et 17 ans vous
loyers sur le tableau il va toucher 27 %
du smic et ça va évoluer au fur et à
mesure de ses années de formation et
également de son âge voilà il ya une
petite différence entre le contrat
d'apprentissage et le contrat de
professionnalisation
vous avez tout à l'écran voilà pour vous
expliquer un peu ce qui est important de
savoir c'est qui
quasiment dès que vous rentrent en
apprentissage vous devez les salariés
d'une entreprise et vous commencez à
être éliminé
alors justement on va placer un quiz
et on vous invite à y répondre en
signant un contrat d'apprentissage est
ce que je deviens salariés de
l'entreprise oui vrai ou faux on vous
laisse le temps d'y répondre
alors les réponses
alors pour on était évidemment vrai
quand on signe un contrat
d'apprentissage
on devient salarié de l'entreprise et on
a un contrat une feuille de paye qui est
délivrée par l'entreprise employait
alors là on vous invite à regarder une
vidéo qui va décrire un petit peu la
formation qui est dispensée au cfa à la
faculté des métiers d'evry sur la fia
sur la filière automobile et on vous
retrouve dans deux trois mines et
visiter les différents ateliers
[Musique]
bienvenue dans le plus grand centre de
formation en alternance du sud
francilien faculté des métiers de
l'essonne c'est 90 formations gratuites
et rémunérées du cep au bac + 5 dans
huit filières métiers répartis sur trois
sites
la faculté des métiers de l'essonne
accompagne chaque année 3000 apprentis
et 5000 stagiaires de la formation
continue vers des parcours
professionnels réussi et de réelles
opportunités d'emploi en effet avec un
réseau de 2000 entreprises partenaires
elle affiche un taux d'insertion
professionnelle de plus de 80%
[Musique]
sur le site d'evry courcouronnes la
filière services de l'automobile propose
des formations en carrosserie mécanique
et peinture danse et aux apprentis
aujourd'hui salarié ou chefs
d'entreprises et des apprentis
actuellement en formation témoignent de
leur expérience et bien la faculté des
métiers c'est que entre professeur et
l'élève il ya une bonne ambiance tout le
monde s'entend bien les professeurs sont
là pour nous est
que l'ambiance est bonne ça nous faisait
envie de travailler et de
de réussir être continuée l'avantagent
de la faculté des métiers c'est déjà la
proximité avec tout ce qui est le monde
de l'automobile on est vraiment sur le
sujet au niveau des ateliers on en a de
l'accès au niveau de tout ce qui est
matériel
on a là on a toutes les voitures et
disposition sur le parking de faisans et
haut niveau les équipements surtout dans
les ateliers on est quand même assez
bien fournie on a de quoi faire
on n'a pas à se plaindre de tromelin les
choisit d'apprentissage parce que ben il
y avait un revenu à la clé
grâce à ça on a une expérience
professionnelle en plus et à la fin on
peut finir par être embauchés par
l'entreprise on a choisi ce que
j'apprécie moi personnellement c'est le
rapport qu'on a avec les enseignants le
plus particulièrement monde enseignant
pratique qui lui était anciennement
patron et du coup bah en fait on peut
vraiment discuté avec lui et savoir ce
que lui plus faire et prendre de
l'expérience par rapport à lui son passé
on a passé six belles années quand même
à la faculté des métiers et on revient
toujours bilan positif bah moi je me
sens extrêmement bien ce soit en
entreprise ou au cfa donc je regrette
pas mon choix moi je conseille le cfa
des métiers de toute façon parce que
c'est un métier au bout du chemin en
fait simplement
si tu es deux pas de la gare rer est
organisée autour des espaces verts
arborés le campus d'evry de la faculté
des mythes et de l'essonne propose des
équipements dédiés moderne et performant
deux amphithéâtres
un restaurant d'application ouvert au
public sur réservation un centre de
ressources
et un complexe sportif
deux espaces de restauration sont à
votre disposition
self et cafétérias enfin la faculté des
métiers de l'essonne dispose d'un
service d'accès à l'alternance proposant
notamment une prépa apprentissage et
permettant à la faculté des métiers
l'essonne d'être fiers d'intégrer tout
type de handicap alors n'hésitez pas
rejoignez nous
merci pour ce film aurélie et moi j'ai
une petite question sur la filière
automobile
combien y at-il de deux d'élèves
apprentis dans toutes les sections qu'on
voit là dans la filière automobile à la
faculté de médecine alors on a environ
300 jeunes qui sont répartis sur deux
semaines puisque on a une grosse partie
de jeunes traditionnel tendance une
semaine cfa une semaine entreprises donc
en moyenne on a 150 km par semaine sur
la filière es ce que vous avez pu noter
une augmentation des inscriptions ces
deux dernières années sur cette filière
là où est-ce que c'est assez équilibré
non on a une grosse augmentation des
inscriptions sur la filière automobile 1
on a une cinquantaine de jeunes en plus
cette année on en attend encore plus
l'année prochaine on est d'ailleurs en
train de regarder pour agrandir agrandir
la famille rire avoir des locaux plus
grands pour pouvoir accueillir plus de
jeunes puisque on a beaucoup de demandes
d malheureusement peut pas on peut pas
tout seul et ce toutes les satisfaire
donc voilà on est en train de travailler
dessus je dois me disait manoir
tout à l'heure avec l'arrivée des
véhicules hybrides avec l'arrivée des
véhicules électriques il ya plein de
nouvelles formations qui sont qui sont
possibles et c'est vrai que c'est
intéressant de pouvoir se développer à
ce niveau là vous savez qu est ce qui
justifie cette augmentation de
d'inscription dans la filière alors
est-ce que c'est propre à la filière ou
est-ce que c'est propre à toutes les
filières si vous pouvez réparer ce
qu'elle soit ma chouette pas être sur
toutes les filières effectivement on a
des filières qui sont un petit peu moins
en expansion on va dire mais avec nous
sur la filière automobile
on a cette chance là je pense que c'est
aussi par l'arrivée de ces nouvelles
technologies qu'elles attirent beaucoup
beaucoup les jeunes c'est comme disait
ma note je t'adore la mécanique c'est un
métier qui est là depuis des années et
qui sera là encore longtemps on a tous
une voiture ou plusieurs et et qui
évolue tout le temps qu'ils évoluent
sans cesse donc les innovations et la
logique de ce métier quand on choisit ce
métier c'est que on va voir beaucoup de
choses ça va évoluer on va pas toujours
faire la même chose et c'est vraiment
intéressant enrichissant pour les jeunes
alors si on les 300 élèves excuse moi de
rémy mais combien y at-il de filles
cette année nous n'avons que trois
filles trois garçons les 300 et où lewis
et loisel voilà il est temps et en est
exactement surtout que voilà les jeunes
filles qu'on a sont très bien intégrés
et ça se passe vraiment bien quand elles
sont chez nous elles sont sérieuses
appliquer enfin voilà j'en ai porté -
abriel qui est ici c'est un métier qui
n'est pas que réservé aux garçons il
faut bien se le dire les filles
réussissent très bien dans l'automobile
les garçons sont bienveillants quand
elles sont dans l'est dans les classes
et c'est vraiment vraiment intéressant
on aimerait vraiment ça se développe
davantage effectivement une question
abigaël est ce que est ce que ce métier
est enfin que tu exerces
déjà en entreprise et en apprentissage à
l'école est-ce qu'il est difficile
d'apprendre que physique alors oui et
c'est physique mais on s'adapte
en fait on vu qu'on veut prouver que les
filles qu'avec dans ce métier du coup le
sait et c'est ce qui donne ou
en plus ça tue action plus que de
pouvoir faire ce métier qui est dit
difficile parfois du physique des
candidats briguaient
on continue
donc comme vous avez pu le voir dans la
vidéo sur la filière automobile on
propose de trois types de formation une
formation en mécanique donc en
maintenance des véhicules une formation
carrosserie ray une formation en
peinture sachant que la formation
pointue on va le voir sur slide le
suivante c'est une formation qui n'a qu
il est accessible qu une fois que l'on a
eu ainsi appelée car hausse ce qu'on
appelle une mention complémentaire chez
nous c'est un sable et keith ferrand en
un an on ne commence pas une formation
dans l'automobile par la plainte on ne
peut pas commencer une formation dans
l'automobile à la faculté des métiers
par la peinture on commence soit en
maintenance d'engins mécaniques soit en
carrosserie c'est ce que vous pouvez
voir ici et on commence soit par un ca
paix soit par un bac professionnel la
différence entre les deux le ca paix
d'une formation qui se fait en deux ans
le bac professionnel est une formation
qui se fait en trois ans on prépare un
serbe et on prépare à battre son le
diplôme préparé et ensuite on a une
possibilité en maintenance des véhicules
est en bac pro carrosserie d'encore
train d'amasser note date de particules
en bts comme l'a fait mme anwar
effectivement donc en bts élevé qui se
prépare en deux ans manhwa qu en
première ou deuxième année
d'accord et donc le bts c'est le plus
haut niveau de qualification de diplômes
dans l'affrontement dans la section
automobile à la faculté des salades
discuter des médecines archer mais est
ce qu'il existe un niveau encore
supérieur à excuser moi même
et quand dans d'autres une fois qu'on a
eu notre bts en poche afin que québec
est ce qu'on peut continuer ailleurs on
peut faire plein d'autres choses
ailleurs il peut en des licences mais il
faut aussi aller vers de la préparation
moteur je parle sous couvert de feu de
ma nos actes s'y connaît peut-être un
petit peu mieux que moi là dedans on
peut aller travailler sur les circuits
il ya plein d'opportunités aux 6,1 kg
automobile au mans par exemple on a des
jeunes qui partent là bas ils vont
poursuivre leurs études là bas donc il
ya vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de choix
dans le secteur de manoa excuse parce
que puisqu'on est là dans les parcours
de formation est ce que toi tu es en
première année c'est peut-être tôt pour
poser la question mais est-ce que tu as
l'intention de faire une licence après
tu te poursuivre ou est-ce que voilà
il ya plusieurs chemins qu'il en soit
mois à mai par exemple en fait il ya
certaines écoles certainement
c'était même marque qui demande
un certain niveau de diplôme par exemple
l'école d'un doublé à tigery
la demande même un bts ou un bac pro
maintenance des digues d'accord pour toi
part à ce niveau là affrontant les
terres du pds munich a donc tu sais pas
encore vraiment si tu vas continuer ou
pas si tu va intégrer une école une
école de marque d'automobile c'est un
sud a conduit
donc voilà donc comme vous pouvez le
voir on a beaucoup de deux passerelles
entre les différents métiers on a des
jeunes qui font un bac pro mécanique et
qui veulent s'orienter vers de la
carrosserie par la suite donc ils
peuvent faire comme un beagle a fait un
ca fait carrosserie en un an puis un ca
pépin tueur en un an ce qui veut dire
que très rapidement en très peu d'années
de formation ils vont avoir la triple
compétence mécanique carrosserie
peinture ce qui leur ouvre effectivement
beaucoup de portes lorsqu'ils veulent
ensuite trouver un emploi ça c'est
vraiment le parcours complet vraiment
intéressant je pense qu'à billets
l'année prochaine après son passé à
pékin aux stands à nancy je ne me trompe
pas va vouloir faire de la peinture
c'est ça voilà souvent nos jeunes qui
sont ans est appelé cao qui ne s'arrête
pas la carrosserie fond la peinture
c'est vraiment le plus c'est la voix le
parcours classique le cheminement
classique
une fois qu'on a fait un siècle et
carrosserie c'est la cen-sad et peinture
j'ai une question c'est que vous
connaissez est ce que le secteur de
l'automobile
est en recherche de main-d'oeuvre de
salariés qualifiés tels que vous allez
l'être une fois sorti de est ce qu'il ya
une vraie demande où est ce que le
secteur il est sinistrée d'un point de
vue emploi alors pas du tout il ya une
vraie demande on a des entreprises qui
nous contactent même à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui pour qu'on leur communique
les coordonnées nos anciens apprentis
pour qu'il puisse
trouver des jeunes d'avoir un vivier de
jeunes il ya beaucoup de demandes
d'entreprises ils sont vraiment en
recherche et voilà on n'arrive pas
forcément à réussir à répondre à toutes
leurs demandes d'ailleurs donc on essaie
vraiment un secteur en plein essor ça
veut dire ça veut dire du coup que les
jeunes qui s'inscrivent en sait enfin en
début de parcours de cfa il trouve pas
facilement une entreprise pour les
accueillir en alternance alors c'est
plus compliqué de trouver une entreprise
pour les accueillir en alternance voilà
les
l'apprentissage ça fait parfois un peu
peur aux entreprises dans le sens où on
a des jeunes qui arrivent et on leur il
passe du statut de déco liées au statut
de salarié donc ils ont plein de choses
à apprendre voilà plein de choses à
découvrir la ponctualité l'assiduité
c'est des choses qui voit là sur
lesquels on parque vraiment nous en tout
cas au niveau du cfa on est vraiment
très attentifs puisque les patrons leçon
un appartement où vous rendez vous allez
rentrer au cfa vous allez salariés
l'entreprise aussi bien quand vous serez
chez nombre chez l'employeur que quand
vous serez chez nous ça c'est important
à savoir donc parfois les patrons sans
un petit peu frileux à prendre des
apprentis mais au niveau de la faculté
des métiers on a des personnes qu'on
appelle des charges et de développement
qui sont en charge d'aller rassurer les
patrons pour leur expliquer voilà le
jeune il faut lui donner sa chance mais
ça marche très très bien une fois qu'un
patron a pris un jeune la plupart du
temps ils le gardent sur toute sa
formation voire plus alors il leur
propose parfois bon ben c'est bien après
tombent à la lecture est en bts etc donc
cédé beau parcours au départ simple
compliqué il faut pas faux pas
à baisser les bras il faut faire
beaucoup d'entreprises il faut aller
démarcher il faut pas hésiter à revenir
dans les entreprises pour trouver pour
trouver une entreprise mais voir une
fois qu'on a l'entreprise après ça ça se
déroule très bien
merci
alors du coup nous allons lancer le
second quiz à votre avis combien
d'apprentis trouve
un cdi après leurs études je crois
l'avoir dit tout à l'heure
je vous laisse un temps pour répondre au
quiz
est-ce que c'est 20 % 80 ou 50 %
continue c'est les réponses je pense ça
y est après ils ont donné les bonnes
courses à
80% alors la bonne chose parce que je
suis déconnecté la bonne réponse et des
80% c'est 8 jeunes sur 10 qui trouve un
job à l'issue de leur apprentissage
c'est quand même un énorme taux de
réussite de transformation on appelle ça
de la transformation
alors maintenant nous allons accueillir
cécile
cécile merci de nous rejoindre
cécile est médiatrice de l'apprentissage
pour la chambre des métiers et de
l'artisanat sa fonction sa fonction
c'est de résoudre des petites
problématiques ou des petits conflits ou
des gros entre l'apprenti est le maître
d'apprentissage qui en général le
dirigeant très souvent et donc elle a
trois conseils à nous donner pour bien
se comporter dans une entreprise et
avoir bien ça en tête parce que quand
même
l'apprenti je le répète c'est un salarié
qui se doit de respecter un certain
nombre de
bon comportement de bien bosser voilà
tout à fait donc je te laisse la parole
c'est alors je vous rassure de suite
pour la plupart du temps tout se passe
très bien
donc voilà je n'interviens pas sur tous
les contrats évidemment
mais effectivement des fois il faut il
faut que j'intervienne et puis la
plupart du temps ça fonctionne et ça
fonctionne très bien
c'est juste voir des petits conseils
pour bien enclenché on va dire et bien
démarré son apprentissage
comme vous l'avez dit très justement au
début bas il ya des petits deals
ajustements à faire
eepad vous passez du coup de ce2
scolaire à
salariés donc c'est pas c'est pas facile
voilà donc mon premier conseil ça serait
de montrer sa motivation en premier lieu
alors ça peut englober plein de choses
effectivement la ponctualité faire
attention à l'heure ça montre
effectivement du coup que vous faites
attention que vous faites partie aussi
d'une équipe et que du coup le travail
voilà ne va pas vous attendre et qu'il
faut en être conscient que vous êtes
payé aussi je viens dans le concret ça
changerait ça change tout aussi même si
vous faites des erreurs on est enfin
voilà vous êtes vous êtes là pour ça
mais juste montrer juste sa bonne
volonté
quand vous avez fini une tâche voilà
demander une autre est ce que j'ai bien
fait si
ça ça fait partie effectivement montré
deux
ça montre sa motivation être poli
ponctuelles voilà vous avez le droit de
vous tromper j'insiste j'insiste là
dessus mais effectivement votre
comportement va y faire va y faire
beaucoup et va changer beaucoup de
choses dans la perception de votre
employeur et de votre maître
d'apprentissage
le deuxième conseil ce serait de se
passer de son téléphone portable alors
ça je pense que c'est un point qui
très très compliqué pour pour cette
génération et même là l'autre d'ailleurs
mais bon vous c'est encore pire vous
êtes né avec c'est votre troisième main
donc c'est très compliqué pour vous et
on le conçoit tout à fait on le comprend
donc il faut garder réfection vos bonnes
habitudes de l'école puisque
effectivement vous faites attention
à l'école de ne pas avoir votre portable
vous avez déposé flexion vous auriez
vous avez des pauses pour retrouver
votre téléphone portable sans aucun
problème
et je sais j'y vois là il faudra
vraiment faire un effort là-dessus
essayer de se passer de son téléphone
portable c'est quelque chose qui revient
assez souvent entre l'employeur et
l'apprenti c'est une bêtise mais
effectivement ça peut créer un agacement
du coup
du coup que ça peut se reproduire
plusieurs fois et puis du coup voilà des
conflits qui sont facilement
facilement évitables c6 voir at il dit
une bêtise mais quand on est sur trente
téléphones on n'est pas concentré à ce
qu'on fait et on montre qu'on nous
montre pas sa motivation exactement
exactement il faut voilà il faut
vraiment arriver à s'en passer je sais
que c'est un gros effort c'est un gros
effort mais c'est vraiment le un conseil
un conseil précieux pour que ça se passe
le mieux possible vous aurez des pauses
et vous verrez ça sera encore encore
plus formidable vous aurez plein de
messages quand vous récupérez votre
portable et sa part la satisfaction
personnelle c'est génial
ensuite pour le troisième point vous
avez sollicité des échanges avec le
maître d'apprentissage donc du coup ça
je m'explique quand en deux mots
la plupart des
débuts de conflit
si rarement sur le travail c'est le
relationnel
ou alors les incompréhensions en fait
qui se creuse qu'à ce qu'on ne se parle
pas
c'est souvent c'est souvent la nature du
conflit donc moi ce que je vous
conseille de faire pour bien enclenché
votre apprentissage surtout au début
alors ça dépend des cfa je ne connais
pas tous les rythmes de tout le monde
mais souvent c'est une semaine une
semaine entreprise d'une semaine école
ou deux semaines entreprise de semaine
d'école c'est à la fin de la semaine
d'entreprise le vendredi ou le jeudi de
faire un point juste de cinq minutes il
n'y a pas besoin de il n'y a pas besoin
de prendre une heure façon l'employeur
n'a pas le temps mais effectivement
d'avoir juste cinq minutes pour échanger
avec son maître d'apprentissage pour
savoir évaluer un petit peu votre
semaine ce qui a été ce qui n'a pas été
les points a effectivement à à
améliorer
voilà les choses ou sur lesquels vous
vous êtes trompés et effectivement ça va
instaurer dont complicité entre vous ça
va instaurer un dialogue d'emblée et moi
je vous invite à faire ça effectivement
des débuts pour que ce soit déjà ancrée
on va dire dans la politique
d'entreprise de votre maître
d'apprentissage
et de le continuer si vous aussi vous le
souhaitez et si jamais le maître
d'apprentissage ne le fait pas dû
lui-même voilà vraiment de le solliciter
et de demander ces petites cinq minutes
après après votre semaine écoulée de
d'entreprise voilà c'est hyper important
ce que tu dis là ses cibles parce que ça
permet ça permet de ce cannes et ça
permet de s'auto cliquer son taux jugé
le maître d'apprentissage voilà on
sollicite une pose une question est ce
que ça a été ma semaine qu'est ce que
j'ai de corriger voilà et puis d'avoir
le recul est de se faire évaluer aussi
et puis de le montrer et puis et puis tu
avoir de travail et aussi son
relationnel avec son maître
d'apprentissage je vous rappelle on et
voilà vous êtes dans dans l'humain vous
êtes dans une entreprise vous n'êtes
plus à l'école et ça c'est vrai que
c'est pas facile je dis pas que c'est
facile du tout et c'est pour ça que
voilà n'hésitez pas à solliciter cet
échange l'apa est ce que vous en avez
besoin pendant on va pas vous demander
effectivement d'avoir de l'expérience
tout de suite donc voilà c'est que je
vous rassure c'est très bien très bien
perçu tout à fait une prise on pourra
jamais vous le reprocher c'est ça c'est
sûr merci ses fils derrière tom
internationaux
il y a nous allons continuer
voilà donc avec des petites informations
sur comment s'inscrire à la faculté des
métiers donc depuis
trois ans maintenant les inscriptions se
font en ligne vous allez sur le site de
la faculté des métiers vous pouvez vous
inscrire par vous préinscrire pour
l'instant vous allez voir sur le site
une fois que vous avez fait cette
prescription dont il ya tout un dossier
a complété avec des pièces on vous
demande en l'occurrence vos bulletins
voilà des petites choses une lettre de
motivation un cv ça va préparer à
l'entretien qu'on aura ensemble au
niveau de la faculté des métiers soit un
entretien individuel soit en entretien
collectif sur la filière automobile ce
sont des entretiens individuels qui sont
faits par l'équipe encadrante
illégalement par les formateurs et puis
ensuite je dois trouver l'entreprise ce
qui est c'est ce qui est marqué alors
moi je vous conseille de commencer à
chercher une entreprise dès maintenant
pas attendre d'être inscrits pas
attendre si vraiment c'est ce que vous
souhaitez faire commencer vos démarches
de recherche d'entreprise dès maintenant
c'est important parce que vous allez
être beaucoup de jeunes à vouloir vous
inscrire vous allez beaucoup à
solliciter les entreprises dont va il
faut commencer dès maintenant c'est très
important
si à l'issue de l'entretien vous n'avez
pas d'entreprise ça peut arriver c'est
pas grave nous on va pouvoir vous
accompagner au niveau de la faculté des
métiers grâce à ce qu'on appelle des
ateliers tr donc on va vous expliquer
les techniques de recherche d'entreprise
on va vous expliquer comment faire un cv
qui soit recevable par un employeur leur
expliquer comment faire une motivation
comment se présenter à un employeur pour
avoir pour mettre toutes les chances de
son côté pour effectivement trouvé
trouvé un employeur
donc tout ça on va vous l'expliquer donc
sur nadia pro juste après vous allez
voir qu on a des journées portes
ouvertes voilà et on en a une en
l'occurrence samedi dès samedi donc 5
février de 9h à 17h vous pouvez vous
présenter à la faculté des métiers pour
visiter à tous tout le complexe enfin
que ça soit la filière automobile mais
toutes les autres filières ça vous
permet de voir un petit peu comment
fonctionne aussi pour ce qui est de la
filière automobile vous aurez accès au
plateau technique on aura des jeunes qui
sont en train de travailler en train de
préparer des concours pour le coup
puisqu'on a des jeunes qui s'inscrivent
à des concours le meilleur apprenti de
france ou encore les olympiades des
métiers donc ces jeunes seront là samedi
vous pourrez échanger avec eux bien sûr
ça vous permettra et nous pardon de voir
un petit peu comment comment ça
fonctionne au sein des filières et puis
vous avez d'autres dates le 12 mars le
21 et le 25 juin vous pouvez venir une
fois deux fois trois fois ça nous voilà
vous pouvez venir autant de fois que
vous voulez on sera ravi de vous
accueillir sur sur le site bien
évidemment pour vous pour vous expliquer
un petit peu comment ça fonctionne on
sera vraiment là pour répondre à vos
questions en individuel c'est beaucoup
plus simple comme ça on aura toute
l'équipe qui sera là et voilà je vous
conseille vivement si vous êtes
intéressé par
par l'automobile de ba2 vous déplacer
dès que possible sur le site de la
faculté des médecins et puis et puis si
vous savez pas quoi faire
les prochaine ou dans deux ans ça vous
permet de vous informer de voir un petit
peu les portes ouvertes ça sert à ça ca
c à s'informer se renseigner vos et
plein de questions regarder voir toucher
et c'est le moment de se dire bon ça ça
me plaît ça ça me plaît pas donc de
l'écarter vous faites votre benchmark
mais c'est vrai et c'est le moment là
février voilà il faut les week-ends mais
sa vie il ya plein en ce moment on est
en plein dans les portes ouvertes
d'antan pour tous les établissements
établissements voilà et donc c'est le
moment de vous positionner de dire oh
ben non ça c'est non définitivement donc
j'y reviendrai pas et je vais aller sur
un autre un autre sujet qui m'intéresse
davantage jeu justement comment toi
abigail tu as tu as orienté c'est
pourquoi pourquoi la l'automobile
qu'est-ce qui a fait que ça a été un
élément déclencheur j'ai
dit ouais
ça faisait un moment que ça va devrait
en troisième je voulais aller dans le
hockey sauf que l'on m'a dit c'est pas
un métier de fille à et a dit ça mais
tout ce qui est conseillère
d'orientation
voilà quand on quitte le collège on a un
peu naïf oui moi ça me gâche et du coup
bah
c'est ça et
bah là je me suis dit j'ai 25 ans
pourquoi pas à me lancer c'est le moment
puisque après ce sera trop tard et du
coup j'étais sûr je me suis renseigné
sur internet comment est ce que je
pouvais déjà je leur ai et comment on
faisait pour s'inscrire et je tombais
sur le site de la faculté des métiers
alors rappelle moi ton âge 25 ans 25 ans
donc ouais que qu'avec des étudiants qui
ont vingt et un allemand le même âge
entre
d'accord dans ce groupe-là serait
particulier à huy sur les classes en 1
an souvent on a des jeunes qui ont déjà
un diplôme et qui arrivent dans ces
danses et de la spa dont qui ont souvent
sensiblement le même âge mais on peut se
retrouver sur des classes de pâques avec
des jeunes de saison 20 ans et des
jeunes de 25 ans d'accord voilà
ça se passe vraiment très très bien la
plupart du temps et alors du coup
abigaël quel est ton peut-être que tu le
sais dit citons ces apps et donc on a
compris que l'année prochaine tu fais
peinture et après est ce que tu veux
ouvrir ton garage est ce que tu veux te
salariés ce que tu veux travailler avec
quelqu'un que tu connais en particulier
je sais pas pas mon but ce serait
d'ouvrir ma carrosserie ouais mais
dernier sonne je ne sais pas
mais d'abord à cette expérience
d'accord pouvoir
et donc tu avais créé des portes
ouvertes toi au préalable non pas du
tout en accord et tout et ouamane oise
avec tu fais une porte ouverte ou
plusieurs qui t'ont permis justement te
décider comment tu à appréhender ce à
quoi on a pu racheter avec eux avec un
ami on a pu visiter un peu
du coup ça va finir de automobile au
sein du cfa elle m'a plu et je pensais
que j'ai pensé que je pouvais réussir
dans cette filière
ça se passe très vite à l'ehpad moi
toute
la rage aussi de la faculté des métiers
c'est que c'est un lieu qui est multi
activités c'est à dire que vous allez
pouvoir voir c'est ce que tu disais tout
à l'heure vous allez pouvoir plein de
métiers différents ça me permet de dalé
delà de l'esthétique à la coiffure
automobile électro électrotechnique
tourisme on a plein de métiers sur un
même site donc ça c'est vraiment
pratique pour déjà dit paul un petit peu
voir ce qui pourrait les intéresser en
venant à la faculté des métiers vous
allez avoir plein de plein de
possibilités de métier pour le futur
hockey
poursuivront donc alors
donc là vous avez les contacts sur la
filière automobile
donc avec madame passage quatre
assistants pédagogiques c'est elle que
vous aurez quand vous allez faire les
inscrits en première ligne on va dire
donc moi même tissu la coordinatrice vie
sociale et professionnelle c'est
l'équivalent de la cpu au niveau du
collège avec la partie entreprises en
suisse c'est à dire que je fais le lien
aussi bien que les parents qu avec les
employeurs on a un responsable filière
t-il monsieur stéphane mercier et un
responsable adjoint monsieur cyril
prévost
hockey eh bien écoutez
merci enfin merci aurélie pour cette
présentation succincte mais on va pas
non plus en faire un exposé de trois
heures
maintenant je vois là je vous invite à à
poser toutes les questions qui vous
passe par la tête on est d'accord et
répondre on a vingt minutes à peine 18
minutes il reste 15 minutes à me dit
voilà je vous invite à les poser je vais
donc on en a relevé quelques unes je
vais commencer par poser la première
alors aurélie combien y at-il de
d'élèves par classe dans la section
automobile là on est en section
automobile donc on répond à la section
automobile donc dans la filière
automobile en a fait le choix depuis
quelques années maintenant d'avoir des
freins depuis deux ans surtout d'avoir
des petits groupes donc c'est des
groupes de 16 18 jeunes maximum on a
déplacé les groupes annoncent comme le
disait miguel mais voilà en moyenne ils
sont seize à dix-huit jeunes ce qui est
largement suffisant dans les ateliers
puisque voilà il faut aussi qu'ils aient
la place de pouvoir travailler sur les
véhicules donc 16 18 c'est vraiment le
max super
alors quel type de bts proposez vous
alors qu'on soit bien clair il s'agit là
encore de la carrosserie donc si vous
voulez plus d'information sur les autres
filières je vous invite à vous rendre
sur le site de la faculté des métiers
mais là
quel type de bts en carrosserie vous
propose et je crois qu'on l'a vu tout un
oui c'est ça alors c'est le bts / cpo
carrosserie mais ça va ça peut aussi
être ouvert à des jeunes sans de
carrosserie c'est le bts maintenance des
véhicules c'est le seul que formation
propose sur la filière du feu voilà
celui qui fait manhwa fait de gens qu'on
l'a ouvert maintenant effectivement pour
l'instant qu'on propose ok donc on est
dans la maintenance maintenance des
véhicules tout à fait alors peut-on
accéder un bts en alternance
après avoir un bac
sti2d des gens qui n'ont fait que les
bateaux
alors que tu as fait un exemple en
direct c'est quoi
ça
avec les
systèmes électriques ouais et du plus ça
peut aider parce que
de ça beaucoup d'électronique
d'électricité d'accord car quels autres
matières y at-il dans le bts justement
maintenant
qu'elles ont les majors généraux
c'est quoi cette fois deux heures par
semaine d'accord il ya motte il ya un
petit peu d'anglais oui sinon c'est de
ces deux matières techniques
professionnels s'accordent aussi pour ça
ok alors moi j'ai juste une petite
précision sur le après le bac sti2d pour
passer en bts donc ce qu'on conseille la
plupart du temps s'il n'avait pas
forcément d'expérience en maintenance
des véhicules c'est ce qu'elle fait
madras et son parcours et c'est plus ça
qu'on vous conseille ces deux faits
rincer ap mécanique en un an le vad sans
acquérir les compétences au niveau
maintenance des véhicules en tous cas
une base pour passer en tête que quand
on sort d'un bac sti2d effectivement on
a la compétence antipodes excité mais on
n'a pas cette approche maintenance des
vécus donc c'est bien de faire un
certain moment pour ensuite pouvoir
déboucher sur un bts d'accord c'est
votre recommandation c'est la
recommandation ensuite par contre si
vous avez un bac sti de l'est mais que
vous avez déjà touché avec annick sur
des véhicules
voilà y'a pas de soucis mais c'est vrai
qu'on se commandent la plupart du temps
c'est d'avoir moi une petite expérience
en maintenance avant de pouvoir passer
un bts maintenance alors une question je
pense à laquelle ge a répondu mais on va
la poser avez vous une filière mécanique
en alternance oui c'est ce que j'appelle
maintenance des véhicules effectivement
c'est comme ça que ça s'appelle
maintenant mais c'est bien la mécanique
que l'on fait en alternance aussi bien
un ctc ap quel bac pro 3 jusqu'au bts
pop manoir donc doudou l'intérêt parce
que entre ce qui est dit dans le
l'intitulé voilà servis plomer et le
contenu d'où l'intérêt d'aller de se
rendre ou d'appeler de s'informer auprès
des cfa parce que on pense souvent que
veut maintenant se passer ganic mais non
il y en a c'est vraiment de la mécanique
et la maintenance pour le coup c'est le
nom du diplôme c'est pour ça que le sap
et le bac s'appelle comme ça on prépare
un diplôme à bac pro maintenance
d'habitude ça fait maintenance des
véhicules mais effectivement c'est voilà
c'est de la mécanique si vous venez aux
portes ouvertes vous verrez dans les
ateliers ce qu'on peut travailler
justement maintenance comme le faisait
mal aux adducteurs ont trahis pas la
même chose entre sap et quand bts on
n'est plus sûr du diagnostic la
recherche de panneaux pts sur l'usap et
on va être plus dur de la réparation
classique voilà d'accord alors afin ali
on l'a à chaque fois proposez vous une
filière moto il ya des intéressés
malheureusement n'ont pas encore
fréquence terre c'est ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure l'agrandissement auteurs
potentiels on espère possible et
effectivement voilà ça fait partie des
filières qui sont très très demandée
après rien ne vous empêche de faire un
ca paix ou un bac en maintenance des
véhicules et de faire une année de
complémentaire en moto un petit peu plus
loin donc dans les établissements qui le
propose pour l'instant
alors j'ai plus de questions mais ça va
en fait je vois pas le chat
alors question suivante
alors est ce que beaucoup d'élèves
cumule les deux cap1 whaou cumul en même
temps alors non pas en même temps je
pense que ce qui veut dire c'est des
jeunes qui ont assez ap mécanique qui
conversait ap carrosserie pont qu'ils
ont au final la double compétence et
c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure souvent quand ils cumulent même
les trois capc appelé mécanique ça a
fait mal aux three et c'est après 28 ans
donc ça fait 2 ça fait des
étudiants qui sortent rue du comte hyper
qualifiés hyper qualifiés alors on a
même des jeunes je prends des bacs pro
en mécanique des bacs pro en carrosserie
et d'essai ap en peinture donc il ya
chez nous pendant huit ans alors les
voit grandir ils arrivent ils ont 15 ans
est ressorti en trois ans mais ils ont
toutes les compétences ils peuvent aller
couvrir leurs garages et ensuite ils
nous prennent des apprentis donc ça
c'est génial ça fait pas pour qui est
vraiment top ah oui ça c'est la
transmission à la clé j'ai une question
pour toi ma noah est ce que tu sais quel
serait ton salaire
située à intégrer une entreprise là en
tant que jeunes diplômés quel serait ton
salaire dans une entreprise
quand tu sortiras
as tu une idée
soit environ
1700 1800 euros brut ou net
donc 1700 1800 euros en moyenne
à la sortie de ton diplôme parce que
quand même à salers tard à quel âge
j'enlève enterrement aura 21 ans c'est
quand même un beau salaire et qui sera
amené à évoluer au cours de ta carrière
et ouaddou abigaël ça dépend des
entreprises voyez l'exemple dans
l'entreprise où je me suis ainsi
l'ukraine ce sera à 1500 euros net net
après impôt avec les années d'accord et
il ya possibilité de faire des heures
supplémentaires pour compléter ce
salaire ou ou pas ça dépend aussi des
entreprises ont d'accord
d'accord
alors dans son entreprise quel est le
temps appliquée au travail est-ce que
c'est 35 heures trente sept heures
trente neuf
[Musique]
39 heures en tant que fait appel
d'accord ça c'est la règle voilà oui
c'est l'arrêt c'est bien
vainqueur c'est un apprenti pourra pas
faire plus que 35 heures alors après
c'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure et
c'est si c'est à dire que oui c'est 35
heures sur le papier mais si
effectivement le patron n'est pas finie
tâche et vous devez rester pour
continuer c'est assez malvenu de vie en
patron dans ça y est j'ai fait mes 35
heures je m'en vais voilà soyez un petit
peu conciliant après faut pas que le
patron dans un sens abuse non plus mais
de votre côté voit la situation si vous
êtes passionné vous ferez plus d'heures
je pense qu'à mickaël peut en témoigner
manhwa aussi c'est des jeunes qui font
ça même le week end donc voilà si vous
êtes passionné n'y aura pas de soucis
peau est souple voilà faut faut que ça
soit en bonne entente bien évidemment
elle l'avait bien
ok je la pose parce que mano il va
répondre il varie d'ailleurs alors la
question sénat le bien dit il pour
l'entreprise conseillez-vous un
apprentissage dans un petit garage ou
une grande entreprise norma loy
est ce que tu peux répondre à ça
petit garage ou grandes entreprises
en fait dans les poésies de rage on
apprend on apprend certaines choses qui
sont différentes on apprend à travailler
pas forcément avec les outils de d'une
marque up on
va dire générique un peu partout
dans les grands garages c'est vraiment
spécialisé sur la marque d'accord sur
tout alors est ce qu'on est est-ce qu'on
touche plus à tous quand on est dans une
petite entreprise cedar est ce qu'on est
plus polyvalent quand on est apprenti
que dans une grande entreprise ou là ce
n'est peut-être plus
encadré plus
organiser le travail il est plus
le travail les plus
dans les entre entreprises mais dans les
petites touches attachante donc ça
dépend de sa personnalité si on avait
touché un peu à tout ou être vraiment
dans un service est dédié à
je sais pas moi halima a eu marre voilà
merci manon
ensuite autre question
après la troisième quelles filières
suivre
général ou bac pro
au la dépense que vous voulez faire
c'est ça qui voulait rentrer en
apprentissage en alternance ça va
forcément être vous diriger vers une
cuillère en bac professionnel ou ans et
ap on ne continue pas de projets après
vous avez aussi la possibilité de faire
d'automobiles en lycée professionnel ça
existe aussi dit nous là on vous parle
de l'alternance mais il existe aussi des
formations d'automobiles en lycée
professionnel
une ligne alors je crois qu'on a fait le
tour des questions vous pouvez encore en
poser ma journée
j'en ai quelques unes sous le coude
d'ailleurs elle vient d'échapper
elle était pour abigaël
abigaël
quelques conseils tu donnerais un an un
jeune qui est sensible à la formation en
alternance en l'occurrence
l'apprentissage quels conseils qui lui
donnerait quand ils l'intègrent sa
première année d'apprentissage est ce
que tu as des choses à dire sur ce sujet
ce que tu as fait des erreurs sur
lesquels tu es revenu est ce que tu as
compris des choses qu'elles sont et un
deux trois conseils à donner aux jeunes
je sais pas
peut-être comme toi tu finalement tu
tues tu as fait un parcours un peu
atypique terre ce que tu as fait une
formation c'est de bien se décider sur
sa formation sur son métier futur c'est
peut-être ça c'est bien réfléchir ne pas
se laisser peut-être influencer
par quiconque 1 alors les parents sont
allés peut-être les professeurs aussi
excusez moi vous êtes derrière
par ses copains c'est pas parce que le
copain il fait carrosserie que moi je
vais faire carrosserie ou coiffeuse à 20
c'est bien réfléchir parce que c'est de
ce métier là on va l'exercer longtemps
ou pas forcément toute la vie mais
longtemps donc c'est bien réfléchir se
poser parce que c'est vraiment un moment
clé quoi dans la vie du jeune
g4 donc du coup je me suis vraiment
enchantée dans un métier difficile et
c'est parce qu'il les a j'aimais bien
qu'il n'était pas hyper content
et
du coup il va déjà voir ce que et je n
aime ce que généralement ce que si on
semble dans quelque chose qu'on aime on
est
meilleurs voilà l'état pur que les
meilleurs
lors de prises
d'accord d'être soi même et de faire ce
qui nous plaît c'est vraiment important
c'est vraiment faire ce que tu aurais
toi manoir un conseil à donner aux
jeunes qui nous écoutent ils seront
peut-être pour partie j'ai pas être 10
15 20 % choisiront dans un an ou deux
d'aller vers l'apprentissage
quels conseils tu leur donnes
le conseil jeunesse de d'écouté au
maximum et surtout de bien réfléchir
avant de de travailler normalement enfin
notamment en entreprise bien réfléchir
bien bien prendre soin de faire
attention à ce qu'on fait
parce que en fait il faut rester
concentré tout le temps que ce soit à
l'école ou au travail il faut qu'on se
concentre au maximum pour bien suivre
voilà un bon élève
alors parce que ce que je disais au
préalable c'est que nous on note
nationalement apic
des de l'apprentissage il ya quelques
années l'apprentissage souffrait d'une
très mauvaise image on disait voilà tu
vas faire un apprentissage parce que tu
as de mauvaises mauvaise
mauvaise note à l'école en 4e 3e donc
c'était une voie de garage non non non
non c'est fini c'est fini c'est ont fait
l'apprentissage parce qu'on a envie
d'exercer un métier manuel et tous les
élèves ne sont pas construits pour faire
des hautes études des études supérieures
des études générales et qu' il vaut
mieux être bien orienté jeunes
bons à bigard est apte a perdu un petit
peu de temps mais c'est pas grave tu as
eu d'autres expériences tout à fait
d'autre chose ça va te voilà ça servira
dans ma vie mais ce n'est pas une voie
de garage il ya des élèves est très
brillant qui se révèlent être de très
bons élèves et qui voilà qui qui
s'affirme et qui ce qui se dévoie pas là
au moment leur apprentissage donc sous
cette mauvaise image de l'apprentissage
cas sont là c'est pas vrai et les
chiffres le prouvent il ya plus de 10 à
15 % d'apprentis en 2021 qu'il n'y en
avait à la rentrée 2000 matin qu'il n'y
en avait en 2022 donc les chambres de
métiers de savent bien puisqu'elles sont
toutes des cfa et donc on a enregistré
un pic de plus 10% sur la rentrée 2020
t1 ça veut dire que ça suscite de
l'intérêt des vocations et que ce
système là d'apprendre de formation
convient aux jeunes qui a besoin de
lâcher l'école
une semaine sur deux et des grandes
entreprises d'être sur du concret est-ce
que vous avez tas d'autres choses a
précisé quant à qantas a aurait dit non
c'est complètement ça en fait un
qu'éthiquement maintenant
l'apprentissage c'est ce n'est plus la
voie de garage c'est vraiment quelque
chose de porter ça permet de choisir un
métier qu'on aime et de le faire dans
des bonnes conditions nous on voit
souvent des jeunes qui arrivent chez
nous avec un parcours scolaire assez
chaotique qui ont des difficultés qui
ont des butins qui sont pas forcément
voit la super équipe quand ils arrivent
chez nous viennent nous voir en disant
j'ai eu 20 en maths c'est pas possible
pas à ça n'existe pas et en fait si si
parce qu'ils ont trouvé de l'intérêt on
essaye de faire des maths appliquées au
métier on leur explique le pourquoi
est-ce qu'on fait ça et pour le coup
c'était skiller c'est ce qui leur
manquait à ces jeunes là dans le système
scolaire classique qui ne se retrouvait
pas donc la plupart du temps quand ils
viennent et qu'ils ont choisi ce métier
c'est des parcours enfin voila c'est des
jeunes qui réussissent très bien et qui
en reviennent pas eux mêmes ni les
parents quand on reçoit les parents aux
réunions par an formateurs ils se disent
ça aussi c'est mon fils qui a si si je
vous assure il a trouvé sa voie et ça
change tout oui et puis il faut quand
même être honnête tu as dit quelque
chose les maths appliquées aux métiers
oui on essaye de voir qu'il faut aux
matières évidemment c'est pas les maths
le programme de maths de la seconde à la
terminale de la première évidemment mais
ça ok et c'est pour ça que l'élève
finalement c'est ça me comprend
l'intérêt envers l'algérie est appliqué
aux métiers c'est des maths appliquées
au métier c'est de l'anglais appliqué
aux métiers donc c'est c'est du concret
on est sûr vraiment là le choix du
métier alors il nous reste deux minutes
au pour mon mais détection
donc je vais j'ai encore une question à
poser
alors pour faire le bts maintenance
faut-il avoir obligatoire
obligatoirement pardon un bac pro ou on
peut y accéder par un bac général
bon alors on peut y accéder par un bac
général y'a pas de soucis on n'est pas
obligé d'être passé par la filière par
les métiers et le bac pro avant par
contre comme je disais tout à l'heure on
en revient exactement au même que sur le
bac sti2d c'est bien d'avoir une
expérience en maintenance des véhicules
en mécanique avant d'intégrer le bts
vous pouvez très bien sortir d'hommes
bac général faire une année de
s'échapper en maintenance des véhicules
en un an et ensuite passer au bts à
moins d'être bricoleur dans son garage
être exactement mais ça c'est lors de
l'entretien on parlait tout à l'heure
lors de l'entretien voilà vous verrez
avec la personne qui vous écoutera je
vous expliquerai un petit peu comment
comment ça se passe et on verra à ce
moment là pour l'orientation ce qui est
mieux pour vous
alors eh bien écoutez comme on est sur
un timing très serré puisqu'il ya un
autre web binaire qui va commencer dans
deux minutes dans la pièce d'à côté
voilà je pense qu'on a fait le tour de
la question mais on vous invite
à vous renseigner auprès des cfa nous
allons
postés sur notre site
les des replays les replays de cette
conférence vous aurez vous retrouverez
les powerpoint vous retrouverez tous les
éléments d'informations et surtout si
voilà si vous avez la moindre question
que ce soit les professeurs pour les
livrer aux élèves ou les élèves les
parents d'élèves où la famille est bien
n'hésitez pas à revenir vers nous on a
des réseaux sociaux on a incité nous en
tant que chambre de métiers on diffusera
vers les bons les bons canaux at elle
dit aux portes ouvertes qu'à la qualité
des mets ça m'a ouvert à la faculté des
métiers c'est un immense bâtiment qui a
que trois mille élèves hyper structuré
c'est un des plus grands cfa d'île de
france qui a été il ya quinze ans
d'existence maintenant plus 17 mai est
donc voila merci de votre attention nous
vous souhaitons une belle journée en
notre compagnie à la prochaine et merci
de votre attention
lassouts